thanks for inviting me and this is
collaborative work with my student
Stephen Bennett and a colleague Erin
Benjamin and University of Illinois so
my background is in cognitive science
mostly I do a little bit of machine or
network we've done a lot of experiments
on how people learn and remember
information and this is a bit of a
caricature but a lot of experiments in
psychology the experimenters in charge
the experimenter decides in the exact
sequence of stimuli that somebody should
learn from or remember and the
participant doesn't have a lot of
control the participant is basically
passively absorbing the information for
a later test so in a lot of experiments
on the wisdom of crowds we randomly
allocate people to different problems
people cannot self allocate to problems
that they would like to contribute your
that they have some skill in and that
has some limitations where we take the
the self control out of experiments and
researchers now realize that we need to
understand how people can self direct
how people can have control over their
own learning experience so there's now a
growing body of research on
self-directed control in learning and
memory so here a participant can decide
how long they want to study something
what stimulates a rehearse and this
produces all kinds of complications in
terms of analyzing the data but it's an
important phenomenon to explained based
on research and machine learning we know
that active learning can produce
benefits and similarly active concept
learning in in the human domain also
provides or demonstrates the benefits of
active learning so if people are in
control of the stimuli to learn from
they typically do better in a lot of
experiments a self-directed learner who
is in control is contrasted with a ioke
learner
who gets the exact same sequence of
stimuli
but doesn't have control and across many
experiments the result is that in a
self-directed learner as better memory
learns more than a ioke learner and his
difference is not just due to difference
in motivation it is more motivating to
be in control there's also an inherent
information processing advantage when
you are in control
so self-directed learning also relates
to research on metacognition so
metacognition generally is your
knowledge the knowledge that you have
about your own knowledge your own
learning and this used to be a bit of a
fringe area in psychology but it's
becoming more and more important there's
also more machine learning researchers
who become interested in metacognition
for intelligent systems so one framework
thinking about metacognition is the one
provided by Nelson and neurons so they
are so in their theory there's a
metacognitive model which is a mental
model of the underlying cognitive
process and there's there are two
processes one is a monitoring process we
are monitoring all kinds of signals of
the underlying cognition if I ask you a
question what's the capital of Australia
and then you might think about the
answer and if the answer comes to mind
very quickly then the speed of that
retrieval the fluency can be used as a
cue for for confidence and we're using
all kinds of cues all kinds of signals
from a lower level cognitive process to
drive our confidence judgments another
important aspect of metacognition is
controlling some process so deciding on
some strategy for learning initiating
some action like study disks not that or
terminating an action like stop studying
this material and my recent research
interest is in how self-direction
h-how'd it's important on various online
platforms so some of our research is on
forecasting
and we've designed some forecasting
platforms where people come to forecast
real-world events and people typically
control the questions that they
contribute to so there's a lot of
self-direction
on these platforms and we also study how
people self-direct their own learning on
platforms like Lumosity where people
come to practice their skills and
various cognitive domains so users here
can decide what items to answer users
make decisions about when to study
something what to study when to stop
studying and I'll present to you two
case studies the first case study
relates to these forecasting platforms
and the question is how the
self-direction benefit crowd performance
is this a good idea to have people
choose the questions that they
contribute to and the second case study
will talk about the self-directed
learning on the masa T and I'll end with
some discussion on about the limits of
human metacognition so generally I
believe human metacognition is accurate
despite some claims in the literature
but there are some some limits where we
don't quite have an accurate mental
model of ourselves and feel free to
interrupt me at any point in time so a
couple of years ago I don't know if
people know about the AI ARPA ace
program this was a program funded by I
our body this is the intelligence
version of DARPA so it's the
intelligence Advanced Research Project
activity so they fund research related
to intelligence analysis and forecasting
and they had this forecasting
competition the ACE program in which
teams were competing against each other
to put together the best forecasting
system so each team had to get their own
set of experts in various areas of
world events geopolitical expertise to
design their own platform where people
can produce give a probability rating of
where they think this is the probability
that this event will happen in this time
window and then there was also a
component of aggregating these judgments
across forecasters and exploring the
wisdom of the crowds to come up with an
accurate forecast in the end one team
one team good judgment led by Phil
tetlock and there are many things that
this team did very well but they were
able to put together at teams
collaborative teams of very active
forecasters they call these super
forecasters these were the very best of
the best forecasters that were
motivating each other they were very
active in this as a team on a daily
basis to produce accurate forecasters
accurate forecasts so one feature on
these platforms of the winning team as
well as all the other teams is that
forecasters chose their own questions to
answer and as a results you see it is a
lot of variability in terms of
forecasting activity some are quite
active some are less active and the most
active forecasters turned out to be also
the most accurate ones these super
forecasters that I mentioned those were
the top two percent of forecasters they
were the most active they answered
almost all questions and we looked at
the pattern of questions that people
were picking and which questions you
decide to answer is actually indicative
of forecasting skill so you can use this
to exploit us to to estimate skill but
one main question that wasn't addressed
is duty self directed crowds work is it
a good idea to let
people self-direct to questions that
they provide answers to so this depends
on metacognition if people know their
own skills and the metacognition is
accurate then perhaps it's a good idea
to allow self-directed crowds but we
didn't notice in advance there were some
real questions maybe if people self
direct then you remove some of the
variability that you need in crowds
maybe you you love people all the people
that are drawn to a question maybe they
all have the same insights so maybe need
more heterogeneity also what happens if
nobody chooses a question and you get
very sparse crowds it's it's also good
to go back to Galton's original study so
all talks about the wisdom of crowds
they mention Galton's original study
because there's one important aspect of
a study that gets overlooked so he asked
in his study people at a local fair to
estimate the weight of an ox and to his
surprise he found that the median or
meaning of estimates across several
hundred people came very close to the
true answer and that crowd average was
more accurate than the vast majority of
the individual estimates and that
launched this whole area of the wisdom
of crowds research but unlike what most
people think the crowd was not a random
sample he didn't sort of randomly go and
ask people like was your answer what's
your answer and there was an opt-in
procedure people paid to participate in
this experiment so we don't know if he
got if he achieved his results on the
basis of this opt-in feature of the of
the experiment maybe the people that
didn't know anything about oxes or
weights of oxes decided not to
participate
so we'll report to you on some
experiments we did where we allow
sometimes people to opt in in various
different ways
ideally we would like to do this with
forecasting because that's what we
really care about in our work for our I
ARPA but for now we'll do this with
general knowledge questions so we had to
we had 102 alternative forced choice
questions in various domains of general
knowledge sports math geography and we
did this expounds an MTurk people come
to the experiment and they in one
condition in the opt-in condition they
select 25 out of 100 questions to answer
they read all the questions and then
they can select one out of every four
questions and and produce an answer for
those questions in the control condition
the random condition we randomly assign
people to questions so they have no
control here's some example questions so
the some questions are really quite easy
our bets blind
what's the capital of Australia and some
are well I won't go over it harder
requires some some actual knowledge and
here is the the raw data for the random
condition so I've organized the data
here in terms of a matrix so questions
by participants so each entry is an
answer that people give if it's green or
red so Green is a correct answer red is
an incorrect answer and it's gray if
people will not assigned the question so
it's not much of a pattern you can see
here but not contract contrast that with
the opt-in condition so sort of the
questions here by popularity so the most
popular questions that a lot of people
opted into are on the left and the least
popular questions on the right so you
can see there's all green on the left
so people opt into questions that they
know something about
on the right-hand side there is a couple
of questions seven questions where
nobody opted in to so in that case we
actually in terms of the crowd
performance we actually flip a coin
because we have no other strategy
currently to deal with those missing
missing answer questions yeah we it's
difficult to get questions that are
below ceiling so we want to test crowd
performance so we want to make it very
challenging at the individual level to
get an answer correct so we want to have
a situation with a crowd the majority
vote does well so the student who picked
these questions picked tricky questions
and some of them are so tricky that the
majority of people get it wrong that
doesn't happen very often right as a few
bands of this this redness that's right
this is how I see this in design courses
to where like lots of students will say
oh we should solve this problem but then
no one managed to come up with a good
design about it it feels a honeypot like
yeah yeah in psychology so I'm doing
parkour yet I don't know if you notice
there's a lot of focus on situations
where confidence is somehow inversely
correlated with accuracy there's a it
gets a lot of attention like oh people
are so confident and they're wrong or in
a domain of memory there's an eye
witness who was so confident but
misidentified the person right but if
you look at the overall pattern of
results confidence is is quite highly
correlated with accuracy and it goes
wrong occasionally yes so we we score
the crowds here by looking at majority
rule so the crowd answer is the answer
so she ated with the majority answer of
the individuals that opt in and perhaps
not surprisingly we find that crowds in
the opt-in condition perform better than
in the random condition now this
works because people have reasonably
accurate metacognition they people know
what they know or don't know
so they opt into the questions that they
know with some confidences they're
accurate we also looked at fixed size
crowds if you sample the answers to
equate for the differential crowd sizes
you still get an advantage for opt in so
it's the underlying quality of the
information that's that's better for
opt-in crowds in another experiment we
wanted to know what if we take this a
little further in the first experiment
people had a fixed amount of work 25
answer 25 out of 100 what if people will
let people in being control of the
amount of work that they need to do we
do this an MTurk we still pay the same
amount of money regardless of how many
questions you decide to answer and so
any instruction is you get this amount
of money feel free to answer all
questions or no questions at all and I
thought this would be a waste of money
because people can just opt out entirely
and still be compensated but we find
wide individual differences so here the
matrix is organized from the very active
individuals at the top to the people who
opted out entirely at the bottom there
are two two individuals who are clever
they said okay fine I'll do I won't do
anything done and you can see sort of
all kinds of strategies in between the
crowd performance who was the same as in
the previous experiment it's not better
or worse so allowing people to
self-regulate it did not benefit or hurt
performance at least in this experiment
yeah say a large number of questions
which relatively few people answer like
in some sense you know you know a bunch
of questions where you got a lot of data
and so that's gonna be
pretty robust but I could easily imagine
the stuff on the right third of that for
example like questions is the x-axis and
maybe having relatively few data points
and then eventually being very sensitive
to noise a perturbation of like one
extra person got it wrong or right yeah
so that there's some variability it also
depends on how exactly you measure crowd
performance here it was zero one so
either the crowd gets a correct or
incorrect that leads to wide variability
especially for these the questions on
the right right yeah so I think this
requires more experiments to really get
a better sense of the stability of their
results yeah so I don't think that this
is necessarily that this generalizes
across all circumstances I think there
are ways in which self-regulation can
lead to better results yes yes so the
early compound was that a few people
were putting a lot of money on it to
that insider knowledge and that was a
question and then the Iowa electronic
markets does it with students so it's a
smaller bet larger numbers it's related
to this the question is like how much is
a crowd numbers expertise you see if
you're making money where you're paying
to go the ideas you may be good at
guessing boxes weights as opposed to
just some weird way that crowds end up
knowing better by average yes knowing
something right so if you have no
control over the people that are in the
crowd the larger crowds are better right
so you want to average over more and
more people and typically that produces
benefits for many of these cases you
need 30 or so individuals to do well it
depends on the type of problem but if
you do have some control over who is
part of the crowd in terms of opt-in
right you let people self-regulate or
people pay
which is another form of opt-in then you
don't need large crowds at all and then
small crowds can be quite effective yeah
and there's questions about how does
this relate to prediction markets and we
don't quite have the comparison here
yeah prediction markets by the way they
have not fared very well in forecasting
competitions I noticed a lot of hype or
buzz about prediction markets that but
in all the comparisons that we've looked
at
just simple opt-in strategies led to
much better performance in a than a
prediction market yeah and then finally
one more experiment instead of a
discrete so opt in or
opting out we wanted to get a better
sense of of different strategies by
having people generate confidence
ratings so now people answer all
questions all hundred questions and they
also give a confidence rating for each
question and based on the confidence we
can simulate you know who will be part
of the crowd and these confidence
ratings are on a scale for 50 to 100
percent because it's a tool alternative
for choice question so here's the again
the raw data where the most confident
individuals are at the top and the
questions for which people have a lot of
confidence overall are on the left but
you can see there's a lot of a lot of
differences between individuals and
between questions and now we can
simulate different strategies to create
crowds so one strategy is to say well
pick all the answers that are above X
percent confidence let's say I only
accept all people or a lot of people
continue to provide an answer if their
confidence is above 0.75 let's say then
you would get this answer pattern on the
bottom
and now we can plot the performance of
the crowd that's on the vertical axis
against the proportion of judgments that
are used on the horizontal axis so if if
we set the criterion very low let's say
it 50 percent then we accept everybody's
answer and we create these big crowds
and we use sort of a hundred percent of
all judgments but if we become more
strict and say well let's only accept
people who produce confidence above 75
then you go up this line and
interestingly smaller crowds with fewer
people but more confident responses they
outperform larger crowds now another
strategy is to is to say well let's
let's pick the X percent most confident
responses on a per person basis so
everybody there's the same amount of
work and that's the red line and you get
roughly the same outcomes but at some
point these lines diverge so it's
possible that there are cases where
they're strong individual differences
where some individuals just know a lot
more than other individuals and then
having variable amount of work where
some people just produce a lot more
answers than others that that can
actually lead to a better crowd
performance and then finally we also
looked at more realistic scenarios
instead of opting in on a per question
basis or giving confidence ratings for
each individual question which doesn't
scale very well to larger platforms
where you have to consider hundreds and
hundreds of questions what if you have
people opt in for sets of questions
related to some category of items so
here the the questions in our data set
were organized in various categories
like climate change or Sciences lie
Sciences etc and for each category
people also gave a conference judgement
what's the probability that you'll
answer a question in this category
correctly so now we can simulate opt-in
strategy based on those confidence
ratings and that's given by the black
line so it's not quite as good as sort
of individualized opt-in procedures but
we still find that if you restrict a few
only pick T answers from people who are
confident about certain questions at the
category level we still find that you
can form smaller crowds that are quite
effective relative to sort of randomly
composed crowds what's the distribution
of scores of individuals so let's say
you had me answer 100 questions and you
say oh this okay I got an 85% of Michael
got a 64%
what's that distribution look like Lee
what's the mean what's the standard
deviation because a 10% difference could
be tiny or huge depending on you know
how hard this test is yeah so I want to
talk about it here what we estimated
some psychometric models where we
estimate the the abilities for each
individual person so we get the hyper
parameters on exactly you know how what
is your distribution of expertise was
what is the expertise associated with
with the question and so we can model
both the question differences as well as
well as the indecision ITR model or
something yeah okay yeah and so what did
we learn from that
like how how are that there are even
four 440s for the general knowledge
domains they're very big individual
differences that you could exploit there
are some individuals who know a lot
about a lot of different domains
something like a general intelligence
question that would be to say you know
in the Ox study like the surprising
thing in some sense
when substance was that this meter mean
or median was very close to like
basically the most accurate person in
the room I'm wondering how accurate was
the most accurate person in the room
here yeah I don't have that I think it's
the usual so as you know you if you go
across questions then chasing the expert
is a bad idea so if if you've done well
on one task one particular problem I can
say let's go with you again because you
you did pretty well that chasing the
expert idea is a bad idea
because you might not do so well in the
next problem there is sort of a general
expert general expertise sort of right
so if you tend to be good at one problem
you might be good at other problems it's
still better to chase the crowd as
opposed to the individuals in the crowd
crowds are not more accurate on any
individual question
they're just lower bits like they're
sort of that's right you know it's less
risky to go with the crowd right and
it's difficult to identify the expert in
advance right post talk it's it's it's
always easy but in a true predictive
fashion it's very difficult to rely on
individuals say you know I'm gonna use
their differences in skill metacognitive
skill yeah very different parts of the
crowd rate because it's it's possible so
for general knowledge you probably are
familiar enough with each domain to know
what you know or don't know but there
might there might be limits there might
be domains where you think you know but
you actually
don't and there is such a thing as
metacognitive skill I don't know if
that's what you were getting it or it's
just that just experts are gonna know
anyway and you sir it seems like
everyone is there's a bit of a
correlation that if you know a lot you
also know that you know a lot and so the
people who are less skilled also have
poor metacognitive skill and that's sort
of the downside of this sometimes people
opt in they really shouldn't opt ins not
very often
yeah but it's it's it's unclear how
these results generalize to more complex
domains like forecasting so we believe
that people can recognize their
expertise in certain forecasting areas
but it can also go wrong yeah basically
we're like people have a loser a
superiority and just like they think
they're better than they are if they're
bad but they think they're worse than
they are if they're good that kind of
thing yeah I just thinking of amazing
knowledge design is good at doing
metacognition and was right you saw that
your experience will have to look into
that yeah I think the dunning-kruger
effect is a bit over plate okay in the
literature yeah yeah well talk about
that at the end there's a lot of these
people compiling yeah some it can point
you to the part of this date is
published and I'm part of this data I
can send to you yeah yeah so in ongoing
work and and I would love to hear your
ideas we had this problem of what do you
do with the unanswered questions right
because this does happen and how do we
create some crowdsourcing mechanism
where somehow people come back to these
unpopular questions and we get answers
from
and so we thought of several schemes but
maybe they're clever incentive schemes
that we can think of to to at least get
some minimal crowd sizes for unpopular
questions there's also a big issue I
don't quite know how does will play out
what's the value of self allocation
versus machine based allocation in some
areas an algorithm might have sort of a
big database to work with it knows a lot
about sort of individual differences
might SBM might be able to estimate your
expertise maybe better than yourself and
so maybe a machine should be in charge
of allocating people to problems in the
forecasting domain we've noticed that
this is very difficult for example the
super forecasters were identified after
one whole years of forecasting it took a
long time to figure out who who the good
forecasters are and so maybe self
allocation is still a good strategy
especially when time is important and
you just don't want to go through
endless sort of questions then the
machine algorithm is asking you to probe
your expertise so any any questions
about this part of the work before I
continue whether the process itself yeah
no that's interesting what why do you
think that would affect what I was
thinking people do the act of opting in
is sort of an implicit measure -
someone's confidence but then the
cognitive task of putting a label on
that cognitive score might make people
really wait there's threshold for opting
in or out yeah so these experience were
several either in one experiment it in
or or not in other experience you
produce the conference rating and you
answer the question regardless of what
your conference rating was
but we can do more experiments along the
lines you suggest like well yeah the
confidence that you had in your answer
might make someone change their answer
or be more or less accurate it's
possible ya have to think about that
yeah the line of confidence I wonder how
much happiness play in terms of people
being more aggressive and they would
choose a category or questions that they
they know that they they may not
answered correctly but they just want to
take the risk are they they're just more
confident in themselves so how much
would that have impacted the outcome
later yeah so generally there's a
problem of overconfidence so if you look
at the calibration curves where you you
look at the reported probability and you
plot that against the actual probability
of knowing something people's report of
probabilities confidence levels are too
high so that is a bit of a problem but
the more important issues can people
discriminate between the problems that
they do or do not know something about
and so you can be systemically
overconfident but still realize that you
know more about this domain than another
domain that's what we really care about
yeah the over comments add some noise
but we can still we can still use that
as a signal yeah you you almost answered
this I think with a lot of the other
questions for about confidence you said
there's a difference between knowing
your domain or confidence there's also
the term of the name of the effect you
know overcompensating with confidence
when you don't know and under
compensating what you do what's that
called again
that's the dunning-kruger effect but
you're like who comes to office hours
it's the people that are doing well
so I think it's kind of interesting to
me is like let that all just seems like
noise I can imagine psychological
reasons on both sides or on all sides
where the participants I mean you find
out if there's noise but the more
interesting thing would be to teach
these treaty these things almost as
though they're a bunch of CPUs totally
separate from all in the psychology and
find the people that are actually super
forecasters or what so you said when you
brought that up that it took a long time
and right that's a feature of what
you're forecasting you could forecast
much shorter questions and the iteration
period would be accelerated to find the
forecasters the you know this used to
happen in science fiction people would
want to know what happened in a hundred
years now it's like can you even go
three so you could shorten superior yeah
too far and the super forecasters
doesn't figure out if you could iterate
it seems like on some level you are
trying to find people that are good at
that yes even people in this case is 50
processors or a thousand processors no
matter what the goal is to find out what
set in this is good at it participate
we're good at it so their answers are
weighted more like five thirty eight
thousand poles
whatever yeah there were some
peculiarities of this forecasting
competition we had to produce forecasts
from the get-go so problem comes up and
forecasts need to be generated
immediately for a problem
so we didn't have time to identify
experts right so over several years we
developed some methods to try to
identify experts but that took a lot of
time and then these methods start to pay
off so in the meantime it does help for
people to self identify the expertise
that's but that's a better strategy than
than nothing right not saying it's the
only strategy yeah and yet the big
question is who has control right can
you sort of control the problems that
you want to contribute to or as an
algorithm saying I want you to solve
this problem you are the expert I think
you should do this and what is that
balance of control
you need to trust them but eventually it
would just be like I know what you're
good at computer would you make me
better it through the data and
determining what you're good at
yeah plus you're I'm saying like
eventually that's your illusions II
owned by the machine that's traversing
but the other thing with with these
platforms is user experience right these
are volunteers or occasionally they're
pay we're moving to a paid model but
people don't like to be told what to do
so having some control even illusory
control benefits
yeah makes it fun yeah like a design
question right there's this trade-off of
agency and grab whatever you want to
call effectiveness so like one study I
really liked out of University of
Minnesota in the last few years as they
looked at what people are editing on
Wikipedia versus server logs of what
people are reading Wikipedia and there
is a huge divergence in some topics
where there's just a ton of demand
people trying to read articles but no
one's editing that right and you could
say hey everyone you know I know you're
not self-selecting to edit this article
but we really need help over here or you
could say well maybe that's gonna be
lower quality if we ask people to do
that right because they're not
self-selecting to edit the thing so how
do we navigate this trade-off like in
principle many of these platforms have
to decide are they gonna try to nudge
people to make edits to things they
might not otherwise go to based on your
results what would you recommend that we
do as designers I don't think we know
quite yet we haven't done all the
experiments yet but I believe some soft
nudges might be very helpful the way
some platforms like duolingo uses
various elgin's to nudge people to to
practice this this skill some more and
not this skill because an algorithm
knows like you're likely to forget and I
believe that's that's that's effective
because the users still in control likes
the the whole experience but then
there's also the the machine algorithm
that provides some guidance
yeah it's a hard problem yeah and I
think we need more data we honestly
don't quite know where what that balance
is yeah all right I'll talk a little bit
about the other line of work on Lumosity
so a year ago received some data from
Lumosity just up ahead in San Francisco
people come to this platform to train on
various cognitive skills memory
attention problem-solving here's one
game that people play it's called EMA
flow it's task switching so you have to
decide which way to leaves are pointing
when they're green and which way they're
moving when they're orange
sometimes the leaves can point this way
but move the other way that's confusing
and buy a lot of practice you can
overcome this this in Congress see
effect in another task it's a classic
flanker task you have to decide which
direction is the center bird flying
ignoring the direction of the
surrounding birds it goes very quick but
you're a little more confused if the
directions are misaligned and then this
is the hardest task I think it's a two
back working memory task you have to
decide is this card that you currently
see on the right is that matching the
two cut the card that was shown two
cards ago and the cards are constantly
shifting over to the left so we have
some data from from a large group of
users and various age groups so if a lot
of data to work with and here's some
learning curves the this is performance
measured in terms of the number of
correct decisions per game play a game
play lasts about one minute or so and
these are angular nning curves for
different age groups and different games
so the younger users not surprisingly
they perform better they start at a
higher level and they reach a higher
asymptote and the yellow line here is
it's a very large group of users between
70 and 80 years of age and so
everybody's learning but one important
factor here is that people have control
over when they stop practicing when they
stop playing the game so you can see
that there's the aggregate learning
curves are more noisy on the right-hand
side there are fewer and fewer
individuals contributing to this
aggregate curve so one question is how's
the learning different for people who
decide to drop out early versus people
that decide to Train more is dropout
your your decision to drop out is that
related to learning itself if so then we
have to be very careful modeling the
learning process so here's the a grid
learning for to two different groups the
red line is for users who train over a
hundred games practice four hundred
games and the blue group is for users to
place a moderate amount between 30 and
50 games this is for the particular game
lost the migration for this one age
group twenty to thirty years
and the the learning curves lie on top
of each other dropout is unrelated to
learning itself but as we start to look
at other games and different age groups
we see that sometimes these learning
curves do not over overlap very well
especially for the older users so for
the older users the people that drop out
early they're on a different learning
trajectory their learning wasn't so
fantastic to begin with and they're on a
shot more shallow learning trajectory so
maybe the reason that they drop out is
because they realize they were doing
badly
and that causes them to drop out and
this creates all kinds of complications
for analyzing this learning data so from
a statistics point of view the models
that you need here are models where you
have to worry about the missingness that
there's some learning dated you never
observe because the learner just stopped
and some of this missingness could be
related to the learning process itself
let's see so will we're interested in in
trying to understand this dropout
process and we use survival models to
try to predict the moment when you're
most likely to drop out so survival
models model the probability that some
singular event happens like dropout and
we look here at survival models with
time varying coordinates covariance one
factor we consider is the perceived
performance by the user and the other
factor relates to the temporal lags
between game plays so here's an actual
learning curve of a single user and this
is very typical learning goes very well
in the beginning and then they reach an
asymptote and there's all kinds of
random fluctuations over time so maybe
users are monitoring their own progress
they have a sense of increased
performance over some window of time and
so they might be realizing how things
are maybe not going so well and maybe
that slope that low the the local slope
of this learning curve could be a
feature that's predictive of dropout
another important feature for dropout is
the temporal lags between successive
gameplays people start playing a game
they're excited they played a lot and
then their interest starts to lose a
little bit and so they play it less
often so we can look at the time elapsed
between successive game plays
now if we put these features in a
predictive model we find that
demographics is summer predictive of
dropout we look at performance here and
of a you see the area under curve can
demolish criminais between events
associated with a with a drop out like
this was the last game versus events
where people will continue on to the
next game and one factor that's
predictive is is ongoing performance or
people's perception of their own going
performance the other factor is what was
the time between consecutive game places
that gets longer and then you're more
likely to drop out and you put all these
factors together then you can predict
drop out reasonably well now to
complicate things a little bit more the
learning dynamics here is not just over
successive game plays learning occurs in
sessions so people play a game they
immediately play a game again and at
some point they stop the session go on
to the next session and there's learning
going on to various time skills there's
rapid learning within a session some
point they stop and then in the next
session you get this warm-up decrement
performance starts pretty low and then
they sort of warm up again to reach some
level of performance so previously we've
modeled what's the likely point in time
we stopped old practice but you can also
look at what's the time that you stopped
that session and what's interesting is
people tend to stop when they reach a
certain high point they they reach a
some level performance where they're
satisfied with their own performance and
then stop it's sort of the inverse of
stopping old practice in fact if you
look at aggregate learning curves within
a session and if you tease them part how
many games did people play within a
session you find that these
curves do not line up very well and so
for example in the middle panel when
people trained between four and six
sessions the red line is for pet when
people just play two games and you see
that when people play more games their
performance is actually below that of
the the other learning curve so people
tend to stop when they reach some
criterion level of performance whatever
that is in their own lines and that's
that's yet another sort of complicated
dynamic to consider in these in these
learning models all right so I think
I'll end with the discussion here are
there any questions on the Lumosity data
or we can postpone it until the end
so I've argued that human metacognition
is mostly accurate that we can exploit
it to create better crowds but there are
some limit limits to metacognition a
mental model created by a learner might
not always be accurate there are cases
where let's say students make the wrong
decisions regarding their their learning
strategies so we know that it's better
to space out your learning of material
rather than to mass your study but when
people have a choice they tend to mass
their study they study the same material
over and over again until it feels
familiar and so it could be that you're
using heuristics to drive your to drive
your learning strategies when you mass
study you get this illusion that you are
mastering the material that things
become more familiar and then you might
mistakenly believe that you will retain
this knowledge whereas it's in fact much
better to space it out but it doesn't
feel like you're learning you
you're crying knowledge at the same rate
they believe it's more effective yeah
speaking to the Lumosity games there's a
really good paper called the psycho
psychology of video gaming pays basic
emotional responses that shows that the
highest point of emotional involvement
is actually at the failure when they
almost get it which might suggest then
following with the success which isn't
actually as emotionally involving
provides an emotional stemming out
moment for people's play that's
interesting yeah yeah that's another
dimension to this yeah that's that's
you're saying it's not about so just
very quickly I noticed on one of the
charts that the lowest age group 21 to
30 or whatever it was was the only one
which dropped out while it was doing
better than the average all the other
ones you know example of them kind of
quitting because they weren't good at it
and this would be related to what you
just said in the sense that like if
you're not high performing person on
games or chests and you do well it's
like terrible you know like so there's
no relative you're like I kinda know how
this is working what am i twenty make
green arrows anyway like so this is a
game doesn't have high engagement
inherently because I'm a gateman for
achievements right like wait rooms are
pretty damn boring if you think about it
but because you can become strong become
exciting so you have a kind of
achievement problems whereas games that
are just super fun but are low status
and you would hide them from people
you'd become addicted to them in a
different way so there's a boredom
because you're good at it
or there's a failure because you can't
get the reward
you're good at it that's right and there
are actually very different emotions
just like this one is mmm which are
probably keyed a lot of the noise and
you're you know I think people have
different reasons for doing it yeah we
should the data that we have on the
mostly it's it's large in size but it's
limited in scope so we don't have the
emotional perceptions but it will be
interesting to do some studies he
suggests that it's only when you're in a
if it's too hard you're filled with
anxiety and if you already have the
anxiety of being afraid you're losing
your mind then that could just double
down on the anxiety but if you're strong
you get boredom
so technically probably Lumosity should
only be working with a certain skill
level if they want to get flow states in
the gameplay anyway or maybe a I would
adjust the difficulty level to the
player there's a lot of interesting
possibilities in there right so these
games right away they're not the
difficulty level does not automatically
adjust that made our analysis a lot
easier yeah yeah so another area where
there might be issues with metacognition
this relates to the dunning-kruger
effect so there might be some
misperceptions of people skill relative
to other people so sometimes people
interpret the dunning-kruger effect us
is that the worst the people who have
the worst skill that they believe
they're actually some of the best
performing people relatively that but
it's not quite like that
there is overconfidence there's still
relationship between confidence and the
ranking in the group but there there
could be more over comments when you
assess your skill relative to others
then you assess your own skill relative
to your skill and other domains and some
of you might know about the Bayesian
truth serum this is a crowd aggregation
algorithm developed by didn't Drazen
pray like and that relies a
metacognition of other people
so in Bayesian truth serum you ask not
only what do you think the answer is but
you also ask the question what do you
think the percentage of people is who
will endorse this answer and then
there's a mathematical procedure to
combine this to create a good a better
answer but there are serious questions
that what what about whether the
Bayesian truth serum actually works in
some domains because people might not
know what other people know or don't
know and finally one of the most
interesting challenges is what are
people's perceptions of there are skill
relative to algorithms so we find more
and more cases where people collaborate
with technology and there's complex
issues of trust or mistrust issues of
algorithm aversion so if you collaborate
with some machine learning algorithm
that's vastly superior to yourself but
you've noticed a couple of errors of
this algorithm then people tend to
distrust it going forward even though
they really should rely on the algorithm
and we're dealing with this and this is
the last slide in our current work this
is a new forecasting project funded by
ARPA we not only use human judgment in
forecasting real world events or
forecasting let's say that the price of
gold but we're also using machine
judgment and the goal is to come up with
the best hybrid system to combine
machine and human intelligence and it
gets really complicated we're struggling
with who should be in control currently
on our platform the human is in control
the human can look at a machine
algorithm and say okay that's that's an
interesting forecast I'll copy that
or I ignore it but there could be cases
where this is a bad model and the
machine should really be in charge of
the forecasting product process
especially when it comes to questions
like forecasting the price of gold this
is an area where machines do pretty well
and so I'll end there thank you
you pass cute environments where you can
adjust people's perceive the learning
rate right and you can do this in the
Nazi right you just adjust the
difficulty ever so slightly without the
learner noticing do you have any
recommendations on like how you might
maximize it like your tensions run
engagements these like so messing with
the perceived yes learning yeah I'm not
sure how to do this right so did the
whole point of the platform is you get a
lot of feedback instant after gameplay
you immediately see how what your score
is and various metrics and you get a
score of how well you're doing relative
to other people and people use it mmm
right that drives the engagement knowing
how well you're doing relative to other
people so manipulating those statistics
I'm not quite sure yeah so I was really
interested in this concept that we
briefly touched on about the notion of a
trick question
because in these predictive systems we
sort of decided that the wisdom of the
crowd is such that you can take the
majority response and with better chance
results you're gonna do well um
similarly if if the system were able to
identify which of these questions are
likely to fall into this class of trick
questions right the red bands you still
have the information to make a good
decision you just need to understand
that you shouldn't reject the majority
response right that in these cases if we
can identify a trick question
we can still answer use the wisdom of
crowds you just have to switch our model
um so is there any you know do you have
any assurance or existing work or you've
thought of ways that you might be able
to predict and identify district
questions yeah so the work by Drazen
Fralick on the Bayesian true sim was
specifically designed to address that
problem so if if let's say the question
is what's the capital of Australia right
and most people mistakenly say Sydney
right there's a few Australia
Bert said ananse camber really and I
know that that's the correct and I know
that other people will be fooled so then
on the other question like what do you
think is the percentage of people who
will endorse this answer if there's a
big discrepancy between your private
answer and what you think other people
will say that that can be a signal that
this maybe this is a trick question but
it's it's a it's a very subtle because
you can also give the wrong answer and
believe that you're the only person in
the crowd right it can also go the other
way this is why the Bayesian truth serum
I haven't seen very clear demonstrations
yet that you can overcome this district
question problem yeah but this is this
an important area for research